we have the US Open champion Gary
woodland right here on the Rich Eisen
show how are you Gary great brother how
you doing I'm fine two days removed what
are you thinking about it's all trying
to still put it in perspective you know
waking up the next morning with that
trophy next to the next the bad realize
it wasn't really a dream it is real life
special so you it really was on a night
table next day was right next to the
head yeah I just want to make sure
nobody took it and wanted to make sure
it was real when I woke up and it still
where is it right now where's the trophy
right now in my hand
yeah I got it in my lap okay what does
it look like describe what it looks like
up close
well it's a it's a little bit I haven't
even had it 24 hours before I dropped it
so that it's a lot lighter than I
thought it would be but it's special
it's something that I'll tears obviously
forever have you drank anything out of
it
yeah quickly afterwards it didn't take
long a learning experience I actually
was drinking out of the bottom I thought
I didn't know the top came off so I
learned a lesson quickly but what's
what's been in there a vodka a lot of
vodka no kidding just straight up I mean
man that's how we've mixed some we
thrown a little sprite in there a little
bit of water but particularly there's
been vodka in there well just
congratulations on all of that when did
you I mean I obviously you've won on the
tour before did you have a sensation
leading up to this tournament playing in
it that you've felt before on on
tournaments that you've won Gary is
there any similarities to anything that
you can relate you know not really
besides I played well lately especially
in major championships I I had I was
leading through 36 last year Bellerive
in the pga end up finishing six but i
learned a lot so hospital because the
first time i was in contention in a
major playing with tiger on Sunday just
taken in that atmosphere learning you
know that I left for snikt me especially
early in that round so I took a lot of
that and fast forward played solid this
year I had us come to the PGA I have
another top-10 there this year okay and
Pebble Beach is Pebble Beach you know
obviously the views the golf course
speaks for itself but it's a special
place for me and so I was excited to be
there I do out my game was in good shape
and it transcended do it very special
week and what's your favorite hole in
the course you know I mean it's hard not
to say 18
I didn't say well I came until the last
the last day that would make a birdie
putt it's just it's such an iconic whole
ocean right there but you can
risk/reward you could make three there
you can make seven there unfortunately
I gave myself a chance driving ball in
the fairway a couple times but it's just
such a beautiful golf hole it doesn't
get any better than that
yeah I've got a good Gary woodland here
in the Rich Eisen show look I'm a hacker
and it's very difficult for me to
concentrate if you know on pebble I'm
beyond for the I wouldn't I'm just
wondering do you at any point even
though you're you're locked in clearly
and it's the the biggest tournament of
your life that you're winning do you do
you look around in a while that's
Pacific Ocean this Pebble Beach is
pretty amazing June I think it helps me
to be honest with you the views I mean
the crowds were so so big the energy the
noise was amazing but looking out it's
so peaceful a better word and beautiful
that it kind of just brought me back
down to life's real quick and just
trying to take it in I'm a kid from
Kansas I'm as far away from the ocean is
we're gonna get sitting there and
looking at those views that was special
that kind of let me get on get out of
what was going on for a second put it
back in perspective and then get back to
work when I needed to step up and hit a
shot how often though did you peek at
the leaderboard knowing that you had one
of the most red-hot golfers in the
history of major tournaments on your
heels Gary and Brooks cup yeah of course
I didn't he was right in front of me so
I could I could really see what was
going on in the noise you could tell the
roars when he was making Bernie's I was
you know fortunately for me I got off to
a good start where I was not was a huge
part in the day me making birdies early
because he came in hot and you knew he
was going to make a charge he's been
doing it overseas now for years he just
seems like he steps up to that mall and
he just loved it so I do I need to do
that now I'm playing with Justin Rose
obviously one of the top players in the
world as well
what he's doing so it was important for
me to to kind of withstand all that
early in the round and I did that Gary
woodland US Open champion here on the
Rich Eisen show and then speaking of the
word beautiful I thought it was a
wonderful moment with your folks and
obviously your dad it's Father's Day is
it true that your dad had a heart attack
when you were earning your Tour card ten
years ago at Pebble Beach is that a true
story Gary woodland he actually had a
heart attack when I was playing Pebble
my rookie year 2009 I mean I mean that
just you know you really can't make that
up for me full circle for me to win my
first major at Pebble Beach on Father's
Day with my dad staying in there you
know it's emotional thinking about it
but it doesn't get any better that I
couldn't have pictured anymore yeah I
mean there he is and giving you that hug
just if you don't mind just what was it
like to see your dad right there and you
did you accomplished what you
accomplished on that day I mean I I said
what do you think about that you know
just we did it I mean that was it's it's
been it's been a full ride I wouldn't be
where I am today without my dad and to
be there and share that moment with him
and you know being a father myself now
you know brings no meaning to life and
yeah you have a baby Jaxen correct
that's you yeah and you've gotten to
this week which is amazing and then I
got identical twin girls on the way so I
needed to keep making versus keep just
keep just one hole just one at a time
Gary okay just one day at a time exactly
and so and because I was reading up on
you and your dad is it true that he he'd
never let you win at golf that this is
something that ever never and anything
in it it you know he taught me as a
young age that nothing's given to you
yeah nothing comes for free so you have
to earn everything you do and I really
feel like I've earned that last week and
that's something I look forward to
teaching Jack's my son and my girls when
they come is you know nothing in this
world given to yes there and everything
you do and that makes the process and
the journey even that more special yeah
we were because we've been talking about
participation trophies a little bit
today Gary before you joined so
there won't be any of those no there
wasn't any of those in the woodland
household it's what you're saying mm-hmm
no there was definitely no no Walla
Walla same up there if I didn't win I
didn't get out I think my dad didn't
talk to me for about two days after I
beat him I was no there was no cell
phones back then I was calling my
grandma telling everybody my dad was
lying to me every time when I was a kid
was there's many more moons before you
beat me son and once I beat him those
those moons were there well before I let
you go here Gary I've got here my my
crack crew has on earth from the media
guide I believe it Washburn University
2000 to 2003 there you are Gary woodland
freshman guard nice haircut right there
number 23 was that for was that for
Jordan number 23 yeah I mean I grew up
when Jordan was over the bowl no no no
NBA team close to us in Kansas so the
Bulls were as close as they got so
everybody was a Jordan fan okay so they
also down the right side have some of
your favorites they called them tippin's
I guess that's a nice nice phrase for a
college media guard for basketball I'd
love to know if these if some of these
favorites from back in 2002 2003 are
still your favorites if you don't mind
okay favorite food ribs yes or no yeah I
would say steak but ribs are definitely
up there okay movie he got game is that
still your favorite no I mean it's no
these are all still there but you know
probably Top Gun gladiator okay
Top Gun interesting yeah all right okay
music Garth Brooks I do listen to
everything else but big well top sports
moment has changed I know that from
winning two state championships we could
we could we could change that one sports
team Indianapolis Colts professional
sports yeah I was a big Peyton Manning
fan it it's funny I'm a I'm a Chiefs fan
now Patrick mahomes has persuaded me and
twist me over but victory's fan what do
you mean mahomes personally is lobbied
you is what you're saying no just his
play I mean I'm just excited
- and Payton retired it was hard growing
up in Kansas you're always the Chiefs
man but I was a die-hard Dayton family
was at Tennessee so he went to the Colts
I became a Colton when he went to Denver
it was a little harder a route for being
in Kansas I didn't go over very well so
when he officially retired my friends
and family persuaded me to I needed to
be a cheese fan grow so now I see
mahomes the way he played last year is
now oh yeah played you back pulled you
back in all right last two here favorite
TV show ESPN yeah I'm a big sports guy
don't watch a lot of TV when I do I'm
catching up on it's been okay so
SportsCenter from back in the day is
what you're saying go for sure okay so
then favorite sports announcer Chris
Berman Gary you know the name of this
show you're on is not the Chris Berman
show right Gary okay and there is an I
in rich and Eisen so I appreciate it
I appreciate you saying that hey Gary
thanks we call really appreciate it
we're right back at you my gosh and I
look forward to having you back on and
and and so much more it really was
wonderful watching what you did in how
you did it and then that great moment
with your family and Congrats on the
twin girls coming YouTube that's Gary
woodland US Open champion for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on Direct TV for free on be
our live or download the Rich Eisen show
app